some absolutely unbelievable deposition
transcripts have been published and they
relate to very dangerous fruit it
appears as though
you know donald trump remember when he
kept talking about the oranges of an
investigation take a look at the oranges
of the investigation it looks as though
that may not have been just a verbal
glitch he might actually have some kind
of an irrational fear of fruit we have
testimony from uh when donald trump gave
a videotape deposition in october
related to a lawsuit filed by some
protesters
against the former president's security
staff who were being accused of assault
and trump gave videotape deposition and
the topic of dangerous fruit
apparently
almost an obsession for trump we're
gonna look at a little bit of the
deposition transcript here
um trump was asked
okay and you said that if you see
someone getting ready to throw a tomato
just knock the crap out of them would
you that was your statement and trump
said oh yeah it was very dangerous and
trump was asked what was very dangerous
and he said we were threatened
with what trump says they were going to
throw fruit we were threatened we had a
threat
trump was asked how did you become aware
that there was a threat that people were
going to throw fruit
and trump said we were told i thought
secret service was involved in that
actually but we were told and you get
hit with fruit it's now it's very
violent stuff we were on alert for that
the questioner says a tomato is a fruit
after all i guess
and
and trump says and you know what
and then
mr mr goldman says it has seeds
to which trump says it's worse than
tomato it's other things also but tomato
when they start doing that stuff
it's very dangerous
there was an alert out that day
trump was asked who were you speaking to
when you said and trump says the
audience
and the question then is so you were
speaking to the audience when you said
if they saw someone getting ready to
throw a tomato just knock the crap out
of them would you
and trump said that was to the audience
it was said sort of in jess but maybe
you know a little truth it's very
dangerous stuff
you can get killed with those things
the questioner says so were you trying
to incentivize people to engage in
violence trump's lawyer objects and then
trump says no i wanted to have people be
ready because we were put on alert that
they were going to do fruit
and some fruit is a lot worse than
tomatoes are bad by the way but it's
very dangerous very very dangerous
now i do want to say it is absolutely
true that a tomato is a fruit fruit is
the sweet and fleshy product of a tree
or plant that can sane contains seeds
and can be eaten eaten as food
and
when you talk about a tomato
the fruit grows from the flower of the
tomato plant and thus tomatoes are
indeed fruits i would make the case
that the most dangerous fruit would
technically be a pumpkin a pumpkin both
is a fruit which a lot of people don't
know but it is
and the record heaviest fruit in the
world was a 2600 pound pumpkin that
could easily kill someone i mean that's
like dropping a small car on someone the
the trick would be of course picking it
up and how you pick it up i don't know
guys this is crazy
fruit they were put on notice about
fruit and it reminds me of the great
film mrs doubtfire of course with the
late robin williams the infamous scene
of the run by fruiting where a mrs
doubtfire throws a lime at the back of
the head of appears brosnan's character
and there's also for film buffs out
there there is a very famous continuity
error in that scene where robin williams
character as mrs doubtfire takes a lime
and throws it
and then when the cut goes back to robin
williams that very lime that he slash
she threw is back on the pile of limes
this is a true film buff thing for those
who care about this type of trivia but
very strange a very bizarre obsession on
the dangers of
fruit uh
there it is and maybe this relates to
trump
and flushing toilets 10 to 15 times
somehow if it says anything about his
diet i don't know
this isn't maybe an even stranger video
that i have to play for you today
uh there's this guy roger stone roger
stone was a former associate of donald
trump's he was charged he was convicted
he was pardoned by donald trump and you
know this week we've been going back and
forth about when mike pillow says these
crazy things mike lindell ceo of
mypillow does he believe them or does he
not and we looked at all sorts of
different evidence pointing one way and
pointing the other way i genuinely have
the same question with the clip i'm
about to play for you roger stone
appeared on some show who even knows
what it is let's let's see if we can
figure it out
um he appeared on elijah streams
which is some kind of religious show
okay
and he said
that he has discovered that there's a
satanic portal at the white house and he
presents pictures which he claims proves
it now again my question is
is he for real or is he just cow towing
to whoever is interviewing him and in
this case it's a religious nuttery show
so he has to bring some religious
nuttery let's take a look see if we can
figure it out there you can see it uh
it's very very clear uh it doesn't move
day or night it's harder to see during
the day but you you see it at night
uh and
i'm absolutely convinced
about the inherent there it is again
about the inherent evil of what's going
on in the white house what's going on
in the country right and i think it's
imperative
that people know about this the people
of good faith that christians know about
this and we begin a a national
essentially a prayer assault to close
the portal so i guess what he's pointing
to as the portal
if you're only listening there are
images where there's almost like a
smudge of some kind above the white
house
and it could be anything from i mean
quite literally a cloud
a lens flare i don't know it's very very
strange but i guess that's the portal
that um
he wants closed i don't know let's
continue to close the portal we were
born for this moment i haven't for sure
i've been preparing this
for for this moment my entire life
without even knowing it i just thought i
was a political warrior but this is no
longer a war in the political realm i
for some reason
i'm struggling to believe that this is
his genuine belief i don't know what you
guys think but it's it's just
it's just not feeling like he really
believes this crap that's right
and and i do know how it comes out
because i know how the bible comes out
but i don't know exactly what the plan
is but i do know that closing this
portal is crucial to victory right
and i want others to it's funny how
other people are nodding like this is
the first they've heard of this portal
but yet they're sure that it's crucial
to close it talk about it i want others
to see it you can look it up online you
can go to that live camera it's up every
night folks
down by the way i predict you they'll
now take it down so people can't see it
right but but this is not some practical
joke this isn't some conspiracy theory
i'm absolutely convinced that this is a
it's
demonic yeah it is a statement portal uh
it is access to this earth uh by those
who are evil and only by closing it will
be will we be successful in saving uh
this nation now one of the questions
that to me anytime i hear stuff like
this i i just there's questions that
seem natural right so like for example
when i hear about uh noah's ark for
example
um and they say they were there's two of
every species a male and a female it's
like okay well
it might be plausible if you think of
like well giraffe and hippo and two
chickens and whatever else
but do you really understand what you
mean by two of every species we're
talking about two of every kind of snake
two of every kind of bird look at how
many different birds there are two of
every kind of little worm and two it
starts to be kind of like well is that
really feasible another question about
noah's ark what did the carnivorous
animals eat
because if you had two snakes and two
mice snakes eat mice
so
did the mice survive well no we had two
of each type of mouse
plus extras for the snakes to eat
well but you didn't say that at first
the story is that there were just two
these are the types of questions that my
mind go to go to and so when i get to
this is a satanic portal for them to
come to earth
where are they coming from are we
talking about demons or are we talking
about aliens and if it's aliens where
did they come from and if it's demons
where do they normally live and why do
they even need a portal in other words
if demons are really ethereal and
omnipresent
why do you need a visible portal don't
they just appear particularly if they
are deputized by god with the sa it just
never makes sense and if you ask these
questions it's always
listen
we it's it's too complex for us to even
understand
god works in mysterious ways really well
if that's the case then why would they
use such a simple visible portal it
seems so obvious if you can see it why
wouldn't they come
in a more discreet way you'll never get
answers to this stuff good luck but
you'll never never get answers to this
stuff my question again is do you think
roger stone is sincere in this belief i
don't think so i think he knows this is
nonsense i think he is just placating
whatever audience he's in front of we
have a fantastic program for you today
sign up at joinpackman.com to get
instant access to the bonus show but we
have so much upcoming for you
here and then we have the bonus show and
then tonight i'll be streaming the trump
rally live from nebraska this one
doesn't start till 9pm eastern i'll go
live at 8pm eastern so i hope to see you
then but we have a hell of a show for
you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is funded by our
audience it's an incredible thing it's
not a money tree
it's not some rich
entrepreneur
or oligarch funding the show it's just
people like you you sign up at
joinpakman.com
you get the show commercial free you get
the bonus show produced every day
exclusively exclusively for our members
and uh everybody loves it you can sign
up at join joinpackman.com
let's hear from people in the audience
without you i'm a guy in a room with a
microphone talking to no one and it's
sad so that's why i want to hear from
the people we take calls via discord you
can find our discord at davidpakman.com
slash discord
this could be interesting let's go to
wasif wasif i can't see are you are you
from bangalore is that what it says in
bangladesh i'm from bangladesh
bangladesh beautiful well welcome to the
program
yeah thank you uh uh
it's a pleasure to talk to you so i have
a very specific question i have been you
know like uh i'm someone who's you know
pretty much intrigued and interested in
overall you know let's say uh
international politics right and
especially us i think uh it is very
interesting so this is what i have you
know somewhat you know uh understood
regarding the landscape right now i see
you know we know that you know us has
two major you know like political
parties right but if i had to you know
divide the kind of people that are
currently in you know involved in
politics let's say mainstream you know
uh politicians who are you know working
for the government right so i see like
there are you know uh some very
pro-leftist you know the aoc and you
know the justice democrat types then you
have you know the
completely far-right wing type of people
you know most of them you know endorsed
by trump you can say trumpist and then
you have you know the typical status quo
you know middle of the ground you know
in in a lot of sense they might be you
know like libertarians and in foreign
policy they are more more or less like
neocons
and
right now you know like uh since we have
a war in ukraine and there are a lot of
issues you know
that is you know being generated by that
one and someone who is you know let's
say uh
anti-war
i think there is a chance that you know
like do you think it is possible uh for
the
you know the
the right wings side you know more or
less the extreme side i would say and
the you know leftist side to
come to an agreement and you know form
some kind of coalition like the other
you know international countries where
they you know make sure that they can
form a coalition to get the neocons out
of power or something like that i think
this is this is very interesting wasif
which is
there are there's this new kind of
anti-war right which is it was really
spurred by trump saying i'm going to
hillary will get us into wars but i
won't so you've got that contingent and
then you have the people like me on the
left who have been saying the u.s is too
involved globally in many cases we have
no right and no responsibility to go and
quote spread democracy so couldn't they
come together it's a beautiful idea
wasif but here's why i don't know that
it will work
the trumpists who claim to be against
war they're not really against war
they're for whatever trump tells them
they're supposed to be for and they will
on the one hand say
war is bad we're not gonna do it we're
not gonna do it and then at the same
time say whoa joe biden isn't doing
nearly enough in ukraine he should be
sending troops and he should be sending
drones so they're not genuine in their
opposition to quote war they just want
to be contrarians and they want
something to be able to criticize
democrats with uh oh yeah i think you're
right in that sense but
like uh this is what i want to say you
know i think there is a side of you know
let's say you know the republican fan
base right who is you know like somewhat
you know jumped on this bandage of
anti-war especially you know after you
know tucker carlson is doing all those
stuff you know promoting you know uh
let's say
putin's favorable comments you know even
though you know
from a country like mine you know we
have you know strong ties you know more
or less with russia because uh they were
one of you know the soviet union where
one of the you know uh funding
prime allies who helped us
in our you know
independence yes but i would say that
you know in even in that scenario i
think you know
there has been you know you know like
i've been feeling that you know there is
a you know significant uh possibility of
creating such a scenario where you have
you know people who are on the right but
they will you know at least oppose you
know uh let's say too much you know
getting involved in wars right
and like i said you know uh i don't want
to you know uh
extend this question further but i think
there are some you know left-wing people
right now who are actually you know
getting involved with
tucker right
some people come there call them you
know like let's say looney left or
something like that but no no i
understand i i i think i get the point
it's just a question of whether they
would really work together in a good
faith coalition or whether everybody's
really there you know for for their own
i think i think you know
for a country like you know us who is
you know like uh we have
people like us you know we we see you
know uh us getting too much involved in
war right i think
they should at least try to
you know do this idea like you know we
you know the right says you know let us
you know uh get some of our you know
compromise and you know left to make
some of their compromise and then you
know
the benefit will be getting the neocons
out sure i think sure no understood
listen we've never had a call from
bangladesh before what's going on in the
background i'm so curious what are the
noises we hear where are you oh well my
house is pretty near the you know
somewhat main street i guess there is a
mosque nearby oh you know it's a muslim
majority country uh the only month of
ramadan is going on so you know people
are coming out of mosque basically and
you know the noises are from mosque
beautiful well listen i appreciate the
call thank you
yeah we'll go all right there is wasif
from bangladesh
compelling stuff very very interesting
let's go next to trey from missouri trey
you're on the air
can you hear me yes i can
um thank you first of all thanks for
taking the call dave um i just had a
quick question so
you know one of the things that you've
outlined is that there are sort of three
different republican groups you've got
the pro-business class you have the
social conservatives and then i i can't
remember what was the other group that
it was like the freedom libertarian
people now i would add a fourth to that
now but maybe that's where your
question's going so i'll let you i'll
let you ask the question first
well the question i was going to ask is
that you know tom hartman um you know
had mentioned that there was there was
another sort of a group that sometimes
doesn't get a lot of popularity and it's
the group of people who have a
legitimate economic grievance
about their jobs being taken away from
nafta tpp and all these other um you
know neoliberal trade deals and so i was
wondering is it is it possible that if
the democrats can sharpen their message
on trade jobs protection
protections and whatnot that they could
potentially get some of those voters
back who voted for trump in 2016 and
only switched over to biden just after
the last four years
yes now here's the thing
what we would have to be concerned with
is the group of people you describe
who aren't also part of one of the three
groups i mentioned and who are more
loyal to that than to the legitimate
economic grievance does that make sense
and i can say more about that if it
doesn't
i was just curious because like i said i
i know that it's unlikely that we're
going to help the people who are you
know the social conservatives or you
know the pro-business class just because
we have different views economically and
socially than these people yeah but i
figured that that if we sharpen our
message which i don't know how because
the the current mainstream democratic
party is is so feeble and unable to put
a coherent message together yeah i
thought that that there was going to be
at least one possibility that we could
we could get the people back
economically but by running on an
economic populist agenda that says we're
going to fight for your jobs we're done
letting people take your jobs overseas
and i feel like that might be a
potential so i would tweet one thing
about that for me the running on the
populist messages left and right i'm not
huge on it because populism at the end
of the day is a rhetoric it's not a set
of policy ideas so i'm basically with
your the the
the spirit of your message but i'm less
interested in the so-called populist
rhetoric which can just go nowhere or be
misused i'm more interested in just a
coherent
pro-middle-class worker
social democracy policy and where i am
100 behind you is what you're saying
that democrats could do that might
appeal to some disaffected republicans
it should also appeal to center left
people who just don't vote because they
don't see the democratic party as having
their back so it's not just the
republicans that that would target
so so i think that that that better
economic message and policy most
importantly would actually appeal to
disaffected centrists people on the left
and some of these less ideological
republicans that you talk about
man thanks for the call
thank you trey trey from missouri
very important phone call i uh i love it
let's go next to our friend eric from
cancun we tried talking to eric last
week after
months off and his uh connection just
didn't work we couldn't hear him eric
are you with us today
hello david
as you can see i put next to my name the
topic i want to talk about and to
mention about idols i will ask you if
you heard the sound from eminem
sorry if i've heard the song stan by
eminem
i have i'm familiar with the song of
course
when is it that that song is more like a
musical let's say about the
dangers of toxic fandom because
the song is that stan was very angry
that eminem didn't grow back because
he is a busy guy he should reflect that
eminem
have a hard time
running back to every single fan and you
also struggle with that despite that you
have a dreadful name
and
is it it would be in that
those who are in a toxic fandom would be
feeling a boy within them
and also then it would be that they need
something to fill themselves with
well eric you've really hold on let
let's take it a piece at a time because
what you're throwing at at me is so
meaty and substantive
i think you've identified quite a quite
a phenomenon which i think exists there
is definitely toxic fandom in the space
i inhabit you know on the internet
podcasting youtube
and i think you couldn't be more right
in your analysis a brilliant analysis
that some of these folks become toxic or
obsessed in their fandom through these
parasocial relationships because it is
within them that they have a void they
are trying to fill that that's an
excellent analysis eric
also then i'd rather see you as a friend
than a sun idol because that would be a
healthier way to interact with
celebrities and also so i have my
personal agenda instead of wanting to
take over your life
wait did you say you see me more of more
as a friend than a son is that what you
said no i see you as a friend more than
an idol oh because
because that would be a healthier way to
interact with celebrities and also so i
take my own life instead of wanting to
take over yours
right take control of your life eric i
love it what a message of
self-empowerment
i want to mention that this toxic
mindset would apply with relationships
with hobbies and with religion i will
tell you why um religion many want to go
to the churches and
talk to the priests because they want
answers and solutions for their problems
but morgan freeman when he was god in
bruce almighty he said that they forget
that they have the power to fix it
themselves and captain plans also said
that
eric do you have a photographic memory
um
maybe it's because of my autism
let me finish
sorry about hobbies in the pixar movie
seoul there's a guy named joe gardner
who falls into the sewer and in
afterlife he meets a guy named movement
moving says that when you are too
obsessed with a hobby or a passion you
become a lost soul movement was obsessed
with tetris
and in relationships i showed like
called stephen universe stephen went to
marry his girl connie but then connie
says that she wants to finish college
first and stephen was devastated so his
stepmom garnet tells him that although
stephen and kony would like to be
together they have individual lives and
also that a soulmate is a compliment not
a missing piece whatever is missing
stephen's life connie cannot feel it he
has to feel it
himself eric if i may i have no idea
what you're talking about and that's
okay because i could listen to this
stuff all day i really appreciate you
calling in eric
okay um one last thing i'm not saying
many quirky things in the show but i try
to give the best context i can so i
think it would be better to hear me out
or else i would feel like bru no no no
no i would feel like bruno
eric thank you so much and stay safe
okay
all right there is eric from cancun wow
i am i am exhausted from that that is
really something that that is that is
extraordinary
let's go next to
ricky from charlotte ricky you're on the
air
hey david i'm driving through the
country so if you lose me with my back
connection if you just expand on the
topic but i just wanted to ask you uh
how dangerous do you think it is that it
seems like the ideas of free speech and
like freedom in general are becoming
branded as like a right-wing like
republican uh idea and what can the left
do to sort of um you know to
sort of win some of that back this is a
major problem for the left so i've
talked before about how
the right has claimed for themselves a
monopoly on patriotism they've claimed
for themselves a monopoly on free speech
they've claimed for themselves a
monopoly on being good at business
and none of these things are true i i
won't waste your time
you already know that they're not true
you're asking about what can be done in
the the effect of it
i just think on this in general my view
is hammering people with facts doesn't
really change minds but on this issue we
have to keep hammering with facts
they are trying to ban the books the
book bands that are a 20-year high
it's republicans that are doing it free
speech
they talk about free speech all the time
but they are the ones actually limiting
the speech of teachers of protesters etc
etc i i think there just needs to be an
on on message coordination on this that
they claim this stuff and it's not true
they say they're better for the economy
stocks do better with democratic
presidents unemployment is lower
job creation is higher inflation is
lower we we just we need to all know the
truth and we've got to repeat it repeat
it repeat it
i've kind of noticed about that is it
seems to me like a lot of the
um political commentators on the right
are just more hackish in like the way
that uh they'll they'll cover things and
yes like they have no problems in like
you know defending like hypocrisy with
like uh politicians and leaders on their
sides if it means they can keep their
people in power but it seems to me like
the left especially when you go to like
now what we call like the dum dum left
like the jimmy dores glenn greenwald
like all those losers like they like
they only care about like the
inconsistencies on the left and like
they're so like overly purist about it
and so i feel like that makes it like
harder as well you know what i'm saying
absolutely and you know there's a real
question as to whether those people
really are on the left or are they just
reactionaries at this point but very
well said ricky
yeah no okay i appreciate it david uh
thank you all right thank you there is
ricky
from charlotte we will take a very quick
break if you're holding on to talk to me
and you don't mind
keep holding because we're going right
back to the phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow
welcome back to the show let's go back
and hear from a few more people via
discord you can join the discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go to pablo from
albuquerque new mexico welcome pablo
pablo from albuquerque welcome please
unmute configure your microphone you're
on sorry there we go there you go you
can hear me now icon all right great um
so
um
the last time uh that i called in uh you
mentioned that you hadn't been to new
mexico before um
and it's unfortunate because right now
we actually have some really exciting
stuff um you know i don't know if you
heard
uh if we're making higher education free
for people that uh enrolled in six um
uh six credit courses
and then um you know we just legalized
um marijuana uh cannabis um
and my question is sort of uh
uh
tied in with that
uh healthcare obviously that's one thing
that we tried and haven't been able to
make much progress with
um
do you think that a better way of
trying to
get a universal health care plan would
be also to go the exact same way
along with like cannabis legalization
meaning
um
just having a democrat or uh state
saying
if you're from here you'll get free
health or you'll get universal health
care
and then if you are from one of these
other states that also
um
uh
supports universal health care
you'll have
insurance
covered
through these states
so the details are a bit murky the way
you lay them out but here's how i could
see something like this working
states start to set up their own
single-payer plans okay vermont tried to
do it and it failed but it was a good
idea some state does it okay great
then a second state does it
those states could have an agreement
for um
sort of a consortium of sorts where now
there is a two-state single-payer system
the only part of this that i've not yet
figured out is
what happens if tons of people who work
in other states
move to those states just for the health
care you've got to make sure that you're
capturing their taxes and there are ways
where i mean listen if you have if you
work from home
for a big corporation and you move from
texas to arizona for arizona
single-payer in theory you now live in
arizona you should pay taxes in arizona
but for a lot of smaller businesses and
entrepreneurs you can live in one place
but kind of maintain residency in
another and not pay taxes where you're
living so that would have to be figured
out but i love the idea of starting
single payer or something like it at the
state level and as states do it they can
work as a consortium to expand the risk
pool i think it's a beautiful idea
um yeah and um the reason that i brought
up the um
university a higher university that's
the way that they're
also
they're saying if you've um resided in
new mexico for at least 12 months then
uh you're allowed to um get the um
you know free or subsidized uh health
care right um and so but yeah as you
said for smaller um
places it'd be a lot uh harder to do i
suppose
um
yeah but um
i think that's about it oh there was one
other thing i can't remember all right
well let's save it for next time pablo
from albuquerque thank you for the call
very important issue let's go next to
uh let's go to chris from massachusetts
chris you're on the air
hey david hello
so i don't know if i ever got a chance
to
congratulate you on the uh race against
the majority report to a million
subscribers
oh my goodness you're saying from like a
over a year ago over a year ago oh well
thank you i appreciate the
congratulations
the strategies of stealing the set
panels very effective yeah because
people thought they were like okay wait
a s this is how it worked i stole sam's
panels right
so then people who were subscribed to
sam would come across my videos
they'd recognize the panels and go oh
yeah this is the this is the guy i'm
subscribed to they would see wait i'm
not subscribed i must have gotten
accidentally unsubscribed they would sub
and i would basically trick them into
subscribing to me with my panels it was
genius
brilliant yep but i wanted i called in
to warn you there is a new threat on the
horizon
in a man called brian tyler cohen uh oh
is he getting panels
no well i already noticed that
you already
copied his frameworks
mic stand
oh no no
yes i have never even seen his doesn't
he use a lavalier i've never seen him
use a boom mic actually oh he uses a
boom mic well he copied my frame
he copied my frameworks
all right okay well that will be decided
but the next strategy yep is we got to
get multiple cameras set up now oh yeah
and we gotta go with a cleaner
background maybe dress you in a suit
instead of the zip up button up i used
to wear a suit i got off of it because
it felt pedantic
well okay brian tyler cohen he's he is
like predicted to hit 2 million
subscribers in like 2024 you're not
predicted to hit 2 million until 2027.
oh my god i'll be retired
together here let's work it out i'm open
to all ideas
okay all right good luck i gave you a
couple couple tips there i want to see
him implemented good strategy moving the
show to new york too
because uh i don't know if you knew this
but during the big live event the
majority report was putting out in
boston there was a a plot to steal back
the panels is that right you did a
little 4d chess move on them there wait
sam did a show in boston
yeah uh earlier this year oh wow
interesting i didn't know that or
actually was it i think they might have
done one in new york and rescheduled the
boston show oh okay but that was like
the main i think that was the main
reason they were coming to boston in the
first place to steal the panels when
they thought when i was here back then
oh wow
yeah that's crazy well good thing i
moved out of there of course all right
chris thank you very much we appreciate
the call there's chris from
massachusetts with a lot of uh very very
interesting ideas that we're going to
look into every single one of them very
strongly let's go to george from
littleton george welcome to the show
hey david thanks a lot
thank you
i just had a quick uh kind of thing i've
been thinking about is
how do you combat the just the trumpian
way of
you know kind of talking like um like i
can tell you david
aliens
exist and you question that i just say
well everyone's talking about it
you know just kind of that
kind of way of
speaking well haven't you heard
everyone's talking about it and you're
like whoa
isn't the news reporting on this
and it's just kind of that same
you know oh well you can't trust the
news
uh george i'm not sure are you saying
what are good responses when people say
yeah yeah i don't know everybody says
the election was stolen like how do you
respond when someone goes everybody's
been saying that like if
you tell you that well it means
you know something just absurd like
aliens exist and i just keep
repeating that same type of argument
okay you want to do like a role play
we'll try it you'll be the person with
the belief and i'll kind of do it the
way i would handle it
exactly okay so like tell tell me like
everybody says we know the election was
stolen from trump let's start there okay
so give me that line and we'll go
through it yeah so well the election was
stolen because you know everyone
everyone knows it
how do you know it
george how do you know why do you
believe the election was stolen
oh well you know because everyone's
talking about it um
it's been proven there's there's you
know all the facts are out there okay
who tell me for example who's talking
about
it oh oh fox news yeah fox news is
reporting on it and what did fox news
say
there's just a lot of the uh you know
the the election the uh the integrity of
it the corruption
and in which in which state
did this happen where trump actually won
but the state was given to biden what's
one state that's an example of that
i think georgia was the biggest the
biggest one okay and and how do you know
that trump really won in georgia
yeah there was just so much election
fraud you can't trust it do you live in
georgia
oh so how do you know that that's what
happened in georgia
oh that that's what all the news is
reporting on it okay and how did they
say that it was stolen was it people
uh filling in multiple ballots did
someone hack something
for filling in ballots they were
bringing in the truckloads of ballots
and and
there was al all kinds of fraud it just
couldn't be trusted
and how do you know whether those
reports are accurate
there's just enough enough people
questioning it that that it's it's hard
to believe the results when a lot of
people question things do you tend to
assume that they're correct
i mean it's not necessarily they're
correct but that it just raises enough
questions for me to
not believe it a lot of people say that
the vaccine magnetizes you do you
believe that
now myself personally
okay a lot of people say the earth is
flat do you believe that
no so a lot of people often say lots of
things and you don't believe them why do
you think that this time the people are
right but in all those other cases
they're wrong
yeah
i think you know just
can choose i guess what what
what i believe that anyway i mean it's
actually harder with someone who i know
doesn't believe this stuff but you get
the point eventually we would get to
hopefully just getting them to to
realize
that um that that their opinion is not
really based on anything is that is it i
mean that's the idea i'm trying to give
you
yeah yeah that that
definitely definitely helps when you
when you break it down that way yeah
just start asking for more if the
i mean ultimately it's a better thing
than just beating them over the head and
screaming at them so that's that's my
approach
definitely
all right george thank you for the call
i appreciate it thanks david all right
take care there's george from littleton
trying to do the tough work that's for
sure that is absolutely for sure
uh why don't we go next to uh where are
we going next
let's go to ellie from seattle ellie
welcome
hi david thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
um so uh i feel like the outlook is
pretty bleak here in the states between
don't say gay passing banning math
textbooks because they have social
emotional learning
you know rose probably on the line in
the next few weeks and the midterms are
definitely looking bad for us um so that
thomas homer dixon article suggested we
could be a right-wing dictatorship by
like 2030. yes and it feels like we're
already well on our way there especially
if the right takes like enough
secretaries of state in november and
either win or seal the presidency in 24.
do you do you think it would actually
take that long take until 2030. i i do i
mean
i think that if republicans take the i'm
not going to deny that if the
republicans take the house and senate in
november and then republicans take the
presidency in 24
that by 2026 things could be looking a
lot worse but i still think in blue
states they'll mostly be okay and i
don't think by then we would be a quote
right wing dictatorship so i actually do
think that it is more of a 2030 thing
and not of a next year thing
yeah
okay and my second question with how
bleak these things look to anyone on the
left who's paying attention yeah how do
you not drown in the existential dread
of it all
uh take some days off from the news
that's what i do you know after i'm done
with the friday show friday saturday
sunday i'm tuning it all out and just uh
you know do i'm gardening i'm running
i'm biking etc i think that that's
absolutely absolutely critical
yeah because it's it's
um i mean trump's following is pretty
dangerous oh yes you know
in a country founded by angry rich white
men failing upward it's no wonder
there's such a following for the epitome
of
angry rich white men failing you know
there's this concept called the peter
principle and it's the book is like 50
60 years old and the concept of the book
is that people get promoted up to their
level of incompetence and that's how you
end up with incompetent people so you
know the prototypical idea would be
uh you you take a teacher
and you're like wow this is the best
first grade teacher
so let's promote this teacher to the
person who designs the curriculum for
all first grade teachers and then it's
like well they might be a good teacher
but not good at designing curriculum or
this is my best hamburger flipper so
we're going to put him in charge of
being shift supervisor but it's like
actually he's terrible at time
management and he doesn't know how to
keep people on track so you get promoted
up until your level of incompetence and
i think that celebrity culture allows
that uh to happen much more smoothly
absolutely well thank you so much for
taking my call david my pleasure there
is ellie from seattle and that's going
to do it for calls today we'll talk to
more people soon and we'll be back right
after this short break
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
let's get to this week's mailbag you can
email in info
davidpakman.com also random youtube post
uh comments rather or reddit posts or
whatever else might end up
being featured in this segment and no
shortage of different topics to look at
many substantive which i know many of
you have been saying david i prefer the
substantive emails and comments that you
display we have quite a mix today that's
for sure um jamie wrote in jamie says
hey david
i don't usually write in but i just had
to after this i watch your content
regularly and so your videos show up in
my recommendation feed on youtube one
clip that you posted earlier today this
was last uh late last week was soaking
wet trump explodes walks out of piers
morgan interview but the phrasing of
soaking wet trump explodes brings a very
different mental image to mind this
happened in another one of your segments
when you were commenting on trump's
religiosity where you said
i i don't think trump has ever gotten on
his knees for jesus which again brings a
very different mental image to mind if
it's intentional i love it but if it's
not i thought i would let you know no
jamie
we know exactly what we're doing we know
exactly what we're doing and i
absolutely
love
love this email this this is
ex on this email is genius
on about three or four different levels
and uh i couldn't thank you enough for
it jamie but yes no those the the titles
are not an accident
vinco from norway wrote in and vinco
says
david first off great show i'm a loyal
listener and subscriber and american
expat living in norway
can you spit i know by the way i know
the term expat is very controversial
with some in our audience but i'm
reading the email as written can you
spare a minute to explain why some
people refer to ukraine as ukraine and
others as the ukraine
many thanks and keep up the great work
i seriously appreciate your insight on
current events so
the ukraine
is a reference to the um soviet era
where when you say the ukraine you're
sort of saying
the borderlands and so the reason that i
don't say the ukraine and i understand
it's really not correct to say the
ukraine anymore
is that the country as it exists today
as an independent country
at least for now we'll see what putin
gets away with
is that it's it's the country ukraine
if we say the ukraine it would be sort
of like saying
the outskirts or the borderlands of the
soviet union rather than an independent
country and those are the historical
origins of that i say ukraine i believe
it is correct to say ukraine
brian rhoden this is so funny
um
you you guys will understand why in a
second brian says hey david i'm brian
from toronto love the show
the other day you mentioned your agent
and you had a discussion on getting a
package to send to cnn plus but you were
thinking it's a poor idea correct me if
i'm wrong however i think it would be a
great move cnn plus is likely under
immense pressure right now you could
have a great opportunity to bring
success to the platform demonstrate the
proven content make changes from the
inside plus the contracts they're giving
out aren't too bad either you could
negotiate from a place of power as your
numbers are already proven cnn plus has
since shut down
like as as quickly as i told the story
to the audience wow cnn plus isn't doing
great they're only getting about 10 000
viewers a day we get way more than that
um and it's like all so lame that my
agent and i didn't even think to send a
proposal to them in part because i don't
want to have 20 bosses it's more more
about that brian's like no it might be a
good idea and in the three days since uh
there's been an announcement that cnn
plus is just shutting down
and that's the right decision and it is
a humiliating expenditure of money for
nothing to show for it
i know i've said this before many of you
are probably getting tired if cnn took a
fraction of what they spent on cnn plus
and just said hey we're gonna pick the
top 10 like youtube and podcast shows
in the political space
and we're going to give them a fraction
of the money just to like buy ads on
youtube twitter and facebook the return
on investment would have been
dramatically better dramatically better
but sadly brian there's no more
conversation to have
because cnn plus is going bye-bye
kevin wrote in about trump 2024.
kevin says i doubt that trump runs in
2024 he will blame health or claim it
won't be a fair election trump is too
big of a coward to risk losing again i
do think it would be interesting to have
a debate between two people that have
been president a normal debate the
candidates answer as to what they would
do this debate each candidate has an
actual record i i completely agree that
a debate now is it true let me think
about that has there never been a debate
between
i think that's probably true but
i'd have to actually look at the history
books on that
um
but let's assume it's true that biden
versus trump
would be the first
can campaign where both candidates have
been president
i think that would be interesting
but i also
i mean listen to be honest i worry if
trump runs and is the republican nominee
i worry that he wins and that it's a
really bad four years for the planet
and for the country and for so many
different people so my preference would
be that trump not even run it's it's not
that i'm scared of trump i think the
risk is the same with desantis and by
the way i think desantis would be more
dangerous because desantis is less
incompetent but my preference would be
that both options in 2024
aren't as bad as trump and trump is
starting to mention health
and that's not something he previously
did
so kevin may be on to something there
next message is from ross
ross continues to wait
i guess
for the big smoking gun revelation
about
2020
ross says biden can't even get 10 people
at a rally
everyone knows the dems and dark money
along with republican rhinos rigged the
election it will come out in due time
my question now for the it's eventually
going to come out people
is to say how long is it going to take
we are now
four two
six eight we are 18 months now
beyond the 2020 election hard to believe
but we are
and we still have no evidence of the
fraud that they are convinced exists
so with peace and love and respect and
honesty i want to know how long is it
going to take ross let me know
chicken wrote in
about food shortages
and said this summer this is a
prediction i guess from chicken
this summer when you can't afford food
or there is no food
we'll all be laughing at you
liberals are the capital are real nazis
liberals are the ku klux klan
check your history if you can
read
losers with a capital l listen i mean
this is i'm gonna ignore the innuendo
and the ad hominems
i just have a different opinion i've
been researching the possibility of food
shortages for you know 10 days now and
did a story on it for you guys last week
i believe there will be some products
with limited availability you know if
you're obsessed with
uh
if you're obsessed with a certain
freezer waffle
you might have to choose a different
freezer waffle regionally and
sporadically
but there aren't going to be shortages
of any food group for sure based on
everything i'm reading maybe i'm wrong
you know we don't have to call people
nazis to say i have a different opinion
i just think chicken is wrong here
harrison wrote in about book banning and
says liber this this is a genius this is
genius if it weren't so dangerous this
would be genius harrison says liberals
are for banning books just as much as
conservatives any serious liberal
doesn't want public school teachers
teaching lessons from the bible you know
what harrison that's right and it's not
about banning the bible
it's that we have separation of church
and state
public schools are funded by
property taxes and other funds from
states
meaning
that there has to be separation
between church and state you can't have
a public school
where
everybody goes of no religion and of any
religion and say we're going to teach
the bible here now if you want to have a
comparative religion class in a public
school and maybe some high schools have
such classes using religious texts there
not to teach them as true substance but
to teach what is in them and say here's
what the old testament hebrew bible says
here's what the new testament says
here's the quran here's the spaghetti
monster thing and here's the greek stuff
you could do that in comparative
religion as a history class of sorts
but uh no it's it's against the law
to teach lessons from the bible as in
here's what we learn from the story of
noah's ark here's what we learn about
homosexuality or whether you should eat
shrimp or and that is against the law
you can't do that so yes harrison people
who follow the law are against that
groucho wrote in and says the internet
was and is way too much for low
intelligence folks most of these people
are holed away in the same small town
they were born in completely terrified
of leaving now they have all this crazy
info from snake oil salesmen at their
fingertips and it has kicked their
paranoia into overdrive you're you're
basically
describing the way reactionary politics
works
i mean groucho is using provocative
language but groucho is completely
correct you have
sheltered people
who through a combination of
a lack of economic means in some cases
and
bad parenting and you know i mean we got
to kind of tell it like it is people end
up
extraordinarily sheltered
and then they are targeted with
fear-based rhetoric and they fall for it
and then they go on facebook and they
post it and then that creates this echo
chamber and filter bubble where they get
more of the same stuff next thing you
know you're drinking urine you know
that's it's a sad reality but groucho is
spot-on
and lastly terry says
david pakman will support the war until
the last ukrainian is dead the war pig
pac-man is so
brave
i actually don't know where this is
coming from but the last week or so i've
been getting more and more comments and
questions that seem to assume i support
the russian invasion of ukraine i've
never said anything to suggest that i
obviously don't support the russian
invasion of ukraine
and quite frankly i would love for
people to knock it off because it's just
a waste of time i don't support the
russian invasion of ukraine so i don't
know why you would come to me and tell
me that i do
if you have a comment that you'd like to
see featured you can email info
davidpakman.com we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today become a member
really there's no better time april
beautiful month to do it
sign up at joinpackman.com
you'll get access to the bonus show
you'll get the daily show six hours
before everybody else
it's a beautiful thing